from contemporary art to classic modern
the art at Art Basel is there to be sold
steeped in tradition this is considered
one of the most profitable art fairs in
the world attracting more than 90
thousand visitors each year Joelle wamba
has worked for galleries and auction
houses and is now director of Berlin
Sotheby's together with her husband Eric
she's been collecting Contemporary Art
for 10 years this really is a market
here at Art Basel
these are market prices Art Basel is
really different from other fairs
because a lot of people come here to
look at the art as an investment whereas
other fairs are more for people who just
love art Joelle and her husband live
with their art in their Berlin villa the
big Philip dick who's up he's hanging in
the bedroom appears to be moving an
optical illusion the whole house is
covered in art
there are paper cuttings by Olive X
Neider on the staircase
a series of concrete sculptures are
spread throughout the numerous rooms
imposing themselves on everyday life and
instead of a TV in the living room
there's a video installation my husband
and I generally agree on what to buy we
normally go on our gut feeling and tend
to have the same opinion sometimes not
though if that happens the person who
wants it has to pay for it alone back at
Art Basel Joelle and Ella combi are
searching through a sea of artworks for
items that could form a collection such
as this other piece by Philip D Kuzon
costing thirty five thousand euros what
suit us unfortunately we have a similar
piece in our bedroom and another smaller
colorful work by him this would be a
nice accompaniment because it's in a
different format in style Joelle finds
something she wants to show her husband
on the very first day of the event
it's by Tilo heintzman she already owns
a black-and-white painting by the German
artist for this piece he used a very
delicate orange pigment from Japan the
only possible deal-breaker is that when
we bought the first painting seven years
ago it was a quarter of this price here
we're talking 20 2000 euros
collectors happy to spend millions on
art that catches their eye tend to
gather in the wing reserved for works by
Pablo Picasso Florida Mooney and Mark
Rothko Austrian gallery owner today's
topic has pieces by Gail Basel its
Robert Rauschenberg and Gannett lichte
that could fetch several hundred
thousand euros if not millions
most of these works changed hands within
hours of the Art Fair opening you have
to be careful that you don't sell this
sort of thing to investors these days
there are groups of investors who join
forces with the explicit intention of
buying art as an investment we try to
keep that from happening one of the
pieces that Joelle humba had her eye on
has been sold the gallery owner shows
her similar pieces on her iPad but then
Joelle and her husband stumble across
something else they instantly fall in
love with it's from 2015 this is new
it's by an artist who creates cutouts
he takes existing images and cuts out
parts he also tells us exactly how he
wants his work to hang we like the
position it
something's lost with the cutouts but
something's also gained if you like was
the arrangement the couple are looking
at works in the 22 to 50,000 euro price
range but which one will it be
Jose de Vere
I'd like to take another look at for the
tillow Huntsman I'd like to see it again
and let it sink in a bit I'd also like
to talk to the gallerist about terms
Joelle and ela combi are prepared to
take their time deciding someone else
might get there first but that's a risk
they know they have to take